.
Sean: THA YOU,ETER.
APPRECTE IT.
ALL RIGHT COMEERE WITH
REACTION FROM  FMER SENIOR
ADVISOR TO PREDENTRUMP,
LLYANNE CONWAYOME ALONG WIT
FOER ARKANSAS
GOVERNOR MIKHUCKEE.
KELLY AND, I WILLTART WITH YOU
BECAUSE YOARE A POLLSTER, A
YOARE GREAT AT YR JOB AND
WEAVE KNOWN EACH HER FOR 27
YEARS, FOR CING OUTOUD, ANDYOU L
AND THE LOWT APPROVAL RATING
THEY'VE EV HAD CULNATI 33%
APOVAL WITH QUINNIPIAC.IS THEREE
HAVE, AND THAT IS KEENG THE
CLIME ALAISTS, RELIGIOUSCULT HAE
ANYTNG THAT THEY N DO ON THE
ECONOMY ORN THE BORDERS TT
WI SATISFY THE BASE OF THIS
NEWEMOCTIC PARTY, WHI
MES THESE -- HE'S GOT TO HOPE
AND PRAYHING GET BETTE AND
THAT I NOT USUALLYOW I
RKS.
>> I DOESN WORK TT WAY,
SE, PEOPLE WON'TOTE FOR YOU
IF THEY FEE LIKYOU ARE NOT
LISTENG T THEM AND NOTCONNECTI S
CLEARL NOT.
HES DOWN IN THE POL AMONGST
SUBUAN WEN, KEY TO HISVICTORYN ,
AND YOUNGEOPLE WHO
OVERELMINGLY VOTEDOR HIM IN
2020, THEY HAVE ALLRATERED IN
HIS PEORMANCE OF THEOB A
ONEY ISSUES.
ANHE HAS ATHER PROBLEM Y
JUST ALLUDE  DO WITH
PER DOOCY, HE'SOT A PROBLEM
INSIDE THE SENAT DEMOCRAT BAS.
GARY PETERS,HO RRESENTS THE
STATE OF MICHIGAN, THA ISEARTHEE
MEXICAN BOER, HE IS AGAINST
REVING TITLE 42 BEUSE HE
HEADSP THE DEMOCRATIC SETE
MMITE AND HE ISOOKI AT
THE ELECTORAL MAP IS YEAR AND
HE SEESROUBLE IN PLAC WHE
JOBIDEN'S APPROVA RATING IIN TH,
GEORGIA, NEVA, ARIZONA,
PENNSYLVANIA,ORTHAROLINA, DO
YOU SEE A TRD HER
AND SOE'SOT, J BIDEN HAS
NODY HPY.
I THINK THE ONLY THI DECNING
MORE THAN JOE BIDEN AROVAL
RANG IS JOE BIDEN.
D PELE NOW SEE THAT.
THEY ARE TKING AUT 2024.
FIND THAT TO BE VERY ARROGAN
AT BEST.
UKRAIANSRE SUFFERING,
AMERICANARE SUFFERING UNDER
EOKE OF INFLATION A FOR
INSECURITY, CRE I RISING IOUR CL
TRYINGO CATCH UP FROM THA
SS -- WE HE REAL PROBLEMSAND PAG
ABOUTIS 2024 POTICA
PRPECTS.
BUI HAV NEV SEEN A
PRESIDT AND VE PRESIDENT'S
NUMBERS FA SO PRECIPITOUSLY
AND THEM N WTING TO LISTEN
AND LEARN.
PRESIDENT CLION WE WILL EVER
VE,HEY BOTH SUFFED
GRIEVOUS LOSSE IN TM FIRST
DTERM ELECTION, ANDNAPPED
CK AROUND, MODERATED LITTLE
BIT, AND WON REELECTION.
JOE BIDEN SHED NOIGNSF HIS
WILLINGNESS OR ABITY TO DO
THAT.
>> Sean: YOU ARE RIGHT ON
TARGET, WHI LEADS ME TO
GOVERNOR HUCKABEFROM ARKANSAS,
ABOUT BILL CLINTON BUT HE WAS A
GREAT PITICIAN, ANDFTER THAT
MIDTERM ELECTION,E GO
WAOPED, HE CAMEACK WITH THE
A OF BIG GERNMENT IS OVER,
TH END OF WELFARE AS  KNOW IT
IT
POINT, THERE WAS A STERT SE
SOIER MOMENT THAT WE VAL,
SO HE SHOWED AN ABILITY TO REA
E PUBLIC'S LACK OF
SATISFACTI WITH HISOB, AND
HEURNE HE CHANG FROM HESHIFTED,.
I DON' S BIDENAS T
CABILITY TO DO IT.
I DON'T THINKIS FACE WOULD
>> SEAN, THERE IS NO EDUCATION
IN THE SECD KICK OF A MULE,
ANTHERE IS PROBLEM JOE BIDEN
HAS THAT BILL CLINT DIDN'T.
CLINTO MIGHT GETICKED ONCE BY
THE ME BU HEEVER LET IT
PPEN AGAIN.
KICKED OVER ANOVER AND DOESN'T
REALIZHE H BEEN KKED IN
THE HEAD BY TH MULE.
AND THAT IS HIS PBLEM.
YOU WERE TALNG A MOMENT AGO
AN I BURST OUT LAUGHIN I'M
GLAD WASN'T ON A ANDHE MICWASN'E
BEEN A LTLE TROUBLING BUT YOU
WERE SAYING Y INVE JEN PSAKI
TO COME ONND SPEND ANOUR.
I THOUGHT, THERE IS A GREATE
LILIHO THAT I AM GOING TO
WRITE A UNICO IN THE
PRECHAUN RODEO TOIN THEOT
OF GOL AT THE END OTHE
INBOW
>> Sea WAIT A MINUTE, I
BELIE I MIRACS, IT COU
HAPPENYOU NEV KNOW.
>> WL, THAT WOULDE O THAT
WOULD BE OF BLIC PROPORTION
IF IT EVER SHOD HAPPEN.
BUT THIS IS ANDMINISTRATION
THAT DOESOTANT TO ANSWE THE
QUESTIONS BEUSE EY DON'T
HAVENNSWER FOR TSE
QUESTIS, AND JOE BID CANAY
WANTS TO N AGAIN, LET
HOPE HEOES.
NOTHG WOULD BEETTE TO
FOREVER AND ONES REPUBLICAINOWE.
AND THIN REPUBLICANS NDO
BE VY CAREFUL THAT WE DON'T
RE TOOASILY ON HIS FAIRES,
BUT IF WEHOW THEMERICAN
PEOP THAT THERE'S REALLY SOME
POLICIES WE WOULD LEO
PLEMENT, WE WOULD LIKE TO C
THR TAXES,E WOULD LE TO
SERE THEIR BORDER,E WOU
LIKE TO BRG AMERICA BACTO
THE WORLD WITH A LEL O
RESPEC
WERULYIKE TO SEE THOIL AND
GAS THAS UNDER OUR O FEE
SULY O ENERGY I A
AFRDAB WAY RATHERHAN
PAYI PUTIN AND THE SAUDIS OF
RANSOM IN ORR TO HAVENOUGH
TO HEAAND COOL OOMES.
WEAVE A REAL MEAGE OUT T
THE.
ISIME TO USE I
Sean: NEWT GIRICH WAS O MY RAD,
LLYANNE, AND W BOT AGREE
ITS KIND OF TIME FOR
GRANTED, NOT TRUN ONOE'SR
FAILURE, ALTHOH TT IS PRETTY
TRANSPARENT A OBVIOUS, B TO
LAOUT THEDEAS A PROMISES
AND T ITOWN ON PER THAT IF
YOU ECT US, WE WILL DOHESE
VERYPECIFIC THINGI LIKE THE IDEE
T TO HOLD TM AOUNTABLE FOR
DOOU LIKE THAT IDEA?L DO.
OF THE 1994 CONTRACT WITAMERICAS
GREAT SUCCESS.
SEANTHAT CONTRACT TO ARICA
S SIGNED ON THE PITOL STEPS
RIT BEHIND ITN TH IMAGE,
ATAS FIVE WEE BORE
ELECON DAY.
THISS ALL COMING TOGETHERO
MUCH MORE QUICK, BUT YOURE
RIGHT, PEOPLE VOTE ACCORDING T
AFFIRMATIVE POLICIES,
FORWD-LOOKING, PRIIPLE AND
ONE LAST THING, J BIDEN SEEMS
UNABLE  TDO WITH THE LAST
ESIDENT LEFT, GHT,ND
NTER WERE ABLE TOO, WHICH I
BEED BY T PEOPLE ONC IN
WHILE.PRESENCEAVEO LEAD THE PEL.
PELE A SO EITED NOT TOWEAR A MK-
>> INCIDENT SNDING UP AND
SAYING THI HAPPENED ON MY WAT
CO ON DONALD UMP TCH THEY
HAD TO A MAS STAY ATOME FOR45 DE
THKING OF SUING THE C -- O
SUING AND SAYG LET'SAKE THI
TOHEUPREME COURT.
ONCE IN A WHILE,LAIM A VTORY
AND GOVER THE PEOPL A.
THEY D'T SEEM TO HAV A SENSE
OF PEOPLE, A I THINK 50 ARSIN W
TREMDOUS LIALITY NOT AN
ASSET.
Sean: GOVERNO I WANT TO
GIVE YOU THEAME QUEION.
WOULD REPUBLICANS MAKG
OMIS ON PAPER HOLTHEM MORE
ACUNTABLE, AND TY HAVE TO
HAVE THEIR WDS AND PROMISE
MAH THEIR RHETOC, TIR
TIONS MATCH THEIR RTORI?
>> ABSOLELY, AND I THI IT IS
AN IMPORTANTHING
REBLICANS OUGHT TO BE WILLING
TO BE HELD ACCOUNBLE.
EVERY PERSON WHO I ELEED, I
DOT CARE WHAT PTY TY ARE
WITH, EY OUGHT TO BE
ACCOUNTABLE F THEHINGS THEYSAID.
IF TY DO IT, THEY DERVEO
REELECTED.
IF THEY DON'T, THEY NEE TO GET
THE BO.
>> Sea I THINK T